[Music]
ohayo gozaimasu and welcome to the on
his trailer commentary for Japanese
spider-man the TV series I'm Spencer J
Gilbert that's Joestar mouse yeah dan is
uh I don't know in a different dimension
or dangerous time dan had to review
eight movies to that farewell give them
a break in the meantime though we get to
talk about the honest trailer for
Japanese spider-man which we loved so
much so much fun and if you stick around
to the end you will see some deleted
scenes that didn't make it in to our
already very long trailer how could you
leave anything out of this one I was
glad that this was like an eight minute
trailer it could have been longer it was
41 episodes of television yeah yeah it
was no small feat but man wasn't
enjoyable and I guess for people who
don't know although we sort of explained
it
Marvel licensed spider-man as they are
want to do when they're running low on
cash a Japanese company who then
proceeded to ignore pretty much
everything about spider-man like very
little in common with the American
version but made a TV show about it and
it's fantastic and it like blew up in
Japan yes and then because the licensing
deal right now this created an entire
genre well or popularized an entire
genre of Japanese TV they already had
like guys in fighting suits you know
doing cartwheel alternate but this added
the giant robot yes which is important
forming a giant robot at the end is all
thanks to spider-man yeah who knew yeah
man okay
Power Rangers Super Sentai yep then they
took the motorcycle rider yeah baby they
took the motorcycle and bug part and go
yeah writer I should I should clarify
spider-man doesn't just have a giant
robot he has a convertible if it looks
like a promotional Red Bull car promote
an energy drink
it's called fighter machine gp7 it's got
horns it's pretty sick yeah he drives
that it flies his convertible then flies
into a spaceship called marvel ER Doc's
a marvel ER and then then Marvel er
transforms into leo pardon
yes now it did take me a long time to
figure out the like point eight point B
point C yeah of what all of his stuff
does the problem is or or the great
thing is because it just gets it all out
of the way early is there is an entire
series worth of plot crammed into the
first two episodes of the show it's
amazing and then every other episode is
the exact same formula for assessment
the first two they're like okay
his name's Takuya he's a motorcycle
rider this is his girlfriend this is his
sister who he lives with this is a
little brother of his little baby award
perhaps he finds an alien the alien dies
the the he gives him the power of the
spider the spider summons the thing
professor monster has a grudge against
the alien that he's continuing it just
cram there's been a lot of activity from
an alien group trying to invade the
world lately his dad is an alien is like
a space scientist huh he dies by a river
yep for some reason death by River I
heard then the mentor dies but his body
goes into a spider that speaks to him
and is giving him revenge instructions
but then that spider dies in the second
episode huh and then after that it just
settles into monster-of-the-week
yeah but those first two have old the
plot of the entire show all of it is
held together by just the sickest 70s
funk man oh just never heard anything
fine I got to the point where I was just
watching the show for like yes sweet
sweet melodies yeah and like he has a
theme obviously which was which was dope
yes which they play a lot yeah
[Music]
so there's that but and they play that a
few times but there's like how many
emphasis is at 41 yeah they play it 82
times yeah baby but there there's also
just like looking around funk music
there's a fair amount of loot there's a
lot of percussion like hand percussion
yeah like a lot of this a lot of bongos
there's an episode called the spider
boogie where here's I appreciate is
within the first five episodes the bad
guys have gotten their ass kicked by
spider-man pretty handily and they
completely give up on like just trying
to fight him yeah so they do things like
getting a hit record made and implanting
something in his ear or in the song that
I record that will hurt spider-man so
they can drive him away from where they
want to do evil I like that you go
straight to that like they they first
they try to make a bad Spiderman to
discredit him oh yeah immediately
they're like well we can't beat
spider-man maybe we can ruin his
reputation just like get the word out is
they ain't gonna work you know what
miracle gorilla suit of say they this
band which they create robots of the
bands yeah well the band came up with a
spider-man song on their own and then
they're like we could use this yeah and
that song will be in my head forever
spider-man boogie because they play it
yeah yeah they play it like 22 times in
that anytime spider-man like makes some
headway against the bad guys who tries
to further the plot this band shows up
like just the just the contrivances that
they go through to get spider-man in
trouble like there's this one where they
have to get like a beetle to shrink down
and find out who spider-man is so so the
henchwoman Amazonas who's also has time
to have a full time editing job at
spider-man's girlfriend's paper which
took us a while to realize I was
embarrassed well she's in such a
different costume she's like full like
like murder bikini and then she spins
around and
unlike her she does look like aerobics
Wonder Woman yeah in her costume yeah
she gets a fashion trend started of
wearing a live beetle around your neck
and she just tells spider-man's
girlfriend like it's from Europe she's
like oh okay and she starts wearing a
live beetle around her neck the beetle
falls in love with her of course by the
scent of her perfume yeah as you do yeah
and then turns on its master of course
this is the kind of show we're watching
this is if you were tired of the same
old spider-man movie I hear that into
the spider-verse is great yeah yeah I
will Before we jump into it I will say
this this is um the most fun I've ever
had watching you watch a thing for
honest trade oh yeah because normally
again role very quiet we watch our thing
and every never know that the end yeah
yeah we share notes at the end like
every 10 minutes or so you would just
laugh hit pause and then turn around and
be like so while working with Interpol
yes spider-man just through toothache
alligator off of a bridge yeah professor
monsters digging up the grave of a dead
cat and the cat recognizes spider-man
because his ancestor chopped it in half
it's just like it's mined it boggles so
let's watch our honest trailer for
Japanese spider bites jump in so nobody
asked for this but what the heck this
trailers for us yeah merry Christmas to
us
before you go into the spider-verse
enter an even weirder alternate
dimension 1970s Japan
[Music]
javanese spider-man so yeah that's just
how every commercial break yeah begins
and which is what every show should
still do like I would love it if Game of
Thrones had commercials and did this
Game of Thrones just Fraser Barbour new
NCI SS Miami yep bored from a
short-lived licensing deal between
Marvel Comics and toee
comes a loose adaptation of the
webslinger like very loose quadruple
mascot yep we're instead of the same old
whiny high school with a spider bite
you'll follow a motocross racer with the
enchanted blood of a dying alien from
Planet spider alright who gives him a
flying car that docks into a giant robot
okay and sends him on a mission of
lethal revenge well I shall come in oh
yeah it's like American Spider Man if
Uncle Ben's dying wish for Peter was to
become the Punisher you know it's always
good
so yeah the show's overarching plot or
morale is basically like don't quit on
your on your blood feud yeah that's his
that's the spider-man's only deal is
getting revenge on professor monsters
killing it yeah his only thing is
revenge and I'm gonna spoil the end of
the Japanese spider-man TV show I hope
you don't mind more after 40 episodes of
just [ __ ] around and like kind of
reactive reacting to the monster of the
week and taking them out and as they
rear their head episode 41 is yourself
into spider-man just charging into the
final pace like just like running at
them like oh no point engine and there's
no build-up like to like mmm soon I will
launch my counter-attack it just opens
with him like charging straight yeah
there's no like next week yeah it's the
sense
yeah just open spiders no there's no
dramatic Florence and the Machine song
commercial yeah so it then the episode
proceeds just like every other episode
of Japanese spider-man he finds the bad
guy the bad guy grows really big he gets
in the monster or in the mech throws the
sword at him like one punch man so ever
takes more than one sword vigor
yeah as he yells to make the to make him
explode and then it just cuts to after
all we've been through all the friends
we've made along the way and there have
been many that a cowboy with amnesia
killer Nelson the guy in the scheme
added to other Amazon's one has a bow
and one has a gun after all the friends
we made it ends are spider-man he kills
professor monster and he's just standing
on the beach in his spider suit and he
rips it off and says I've completed my
revenge that's like so abrupt it's
perfect it is perfect he did he did
exactly what he set out right this great
power crap no you get that revenge and
you got it yeah then you just threw your
and then
life he goes back to being a motocross
racer Peter Parker could learn something
from this man give it up
come on man keep coming okay it's
actually nothing like American
spider-man experience a show that's
virtually identical to Power Rangers
where every episode has our hero
transforming after yelling into a
handheld device spider popping pop then
fighting some putties until a cloak this
is kind of impressive but since Jeff and
spider-man actually came out first now
you can say the Megazord is actually
just a cheap ripoff of leo part on it
will make any friends but still you know
you could say it some like super turbo
nerd I'm sure will bring up this was
immediately going is that that whatever
show became Super Sentai ER or the
people behind that that did that style
of show there were two series before
this one but they did not have the giant
robot it they did have things were like
if you transform into the custom guy and
you fight the fight the putties but this
one introduced the thing the robot that
sold all the toys yeah
but then when they lost the licensing
deal all these people who worked on it
went on to create all the shows that
became Power Rangers and I know in that
as they're watching that section in real
time there were people who were
immediately like it's not a rebel then
we got you we got at the end just like
spider-man would have to go tired of CGI
special effects return to a time when
all they had to work with was a rope in
a dream where the monster-of-the-week
made at a fridge using garbage Java
while crawling was more of a steady
wiggle basically tonight's not a million
boob to make them more impressive so
neck put it had to keep getting reused
because someone stole the suit halfway
through production
oh she the put Japanese spider-man on
the case so if you're suffering from
superhero fatigue enjoy a fresh take on
the character that may not be the
strongest version or the smartest
in that episode he has every intent of
killing that dog until a boy those are
not basically yeah he sets he won't he's
too scared to take the dog head off so
he builds like a like a Arnold and
predator style like stick trap like with
spikes and stuff like that and covers it
with brush and just like his like okay
over here and then the boy as they tend
to do ruins his revenge on that dog and
says no spider-man little boys really
get in the way his revenge a lot in this
show and we could maybe we'll talk about
after the tag but like on one hand I get
it like the audience for the show is
little boys but man does he spend so
much time just hanging with and
protecting little boys and telling
little boys who have basically are
conflicted with whether they should help
spider-man or like go to school or go
back to their parents it's like no don't
you want revenge
stay with me great influence you should
not be a Japanese spider-man he's really
an antihero he really is
yeah so dark so much spied on the whole
not cool mutant up up but before you
feel too superior it's still more fun
than the show Marvel was crapping out
stateside these episodes were like man
really use a killer robot starring
takuya's mm face Naruto running and anti
not shorts dramatic faces
dramatic zoos yeah a cowboy here comes
the spy bat I still don't know what the
dad died from your mo no visible wounds
at the river River this is why pause for
one second
Stanley had very nice things to say
about this show mostly because he's like
wow they are actually really pulling off
these things there's not a special
effect short of like looping something
over and over again he's just uh he's
just doing it like they're pulling
spider-man up a building with a crane
yeah he's just wiggling or swinging on
ropes off bridges yeah yeah I
legitimately like how batshit everything
is cut together in the show like you
could look at the fight scenes and be
like well this is cheap he jumped off
frame and now they just did a verse -
cut - now he's in a tree and then
there's a smash cut to him like his foot
falling on a guy's head because he's
maybe falling out of the tree and
kicking but I like it I think it's so at
that weird just like they do so many
things of like he just jumps to a tree
and clearly like just put his hands on
it yeah jumped off but they would just
freeze the frame right here to make it
seem like he had wall-crawling powers
it's like I think it's amazing 1978 like
what are you gonna do do you think do
you think what you're gonna do that's
great let's keep going throw him need to
kill a dog
just do that and then replace it tiny
shorts murderer
[Music]
suicide well this show gets dark poorly
translated episode days yeah and I could
go back to me I love for family
translated monster names
spider-man workshopping his catchphrase
[Music]
she doesn't have to do with whatever
happened in the spider settling on his
catchphrase
okano show spider mom you know cut on
the show spied on you go cut on my show
this hell no you don't think different
she just like yep hey totally McGuire yo
bad we love spider-man nice Joe weebs
are my demeanors yo mama shown in
Pokemon steady tone oh my Cara forgot
okay staccato sketch sorry buddy this
for a night
Jonah Mamata well nigel-murray they're
done what we want to leave got a clip as
inexplicable as the series itself yeah
this is one of those it's easy and hard
to write at the same time because like
you can easily get in your own way and
be like I got to be real clever but it's
like really this shows just he look at
the special effects and then it's just
clip clip when you just let the clips be
fit yeah I mean generally you want to
stop from just describing the movie
because that's not really yeah that just
doesn't translate really well but this
one just describing what happens that's
the joke yep but I die really think it's
fascinating I think that you can see it
if you it's on like Creative Commons
license or something yeah it's unlike
the internet I think streaming yeah yeah
so well let this be our like a plea for
other people to watch the show so we can
talk about it yeah at least watch the
person - yeah at least watch the first -
I don't know I've got some favorites
I'll post an episode list alright some
episodes better than others but now
let's watch some deleted scenes story
[Music]
spider-man
really far from home spider saw and
spider Chad your friendly neighborhood
Voltron man like we believe you think
this was weird just wait until you see
Italian spider-man
this is a parody we just it's weird but
clearly now this was lifting from
nice Guto - you talking about a rockstar
name
don't forget to quadruple mass good kids
yeah zip it up yep
how can we top that Jeff I don't know
what else to say about you just watch
this
yeah I'm so glad we did this dumb show I
already I preemptively I know it's
getting great reviews by preemptively
like into the spider-verse a lot because
it just gave us the excuse to do this
yeah now let's be real we copped out a
little bit a lot on what our original
plan was which is to do basically every
single incarnation of spider-man on
video film or TV that wasn't the ones
learning it was gonna be this it was
gonna be the American show it was gonna
be the 90s cartoon the 92,000 stuff yeah
the Neil Patrick Harris MTV cartoon yeah
yeah that's a lot of TV that's like a
not Doctor Who level but you know 41
episodes a break yeah and honestly like
they're gonna keep doing spider-verse
movies so we can do Japanese spider-man
was in the spider-verse comics yeah yeah
part on they didn't give him his due
no there he gets he gets marked pretty
quick yeah then he got written out of a
ready player one because because we
don't know they wrote in The Iron Giant
who doesn't fight come on he doesn't
want to fight that's no but you know
okay Don he will kill at the drop we
will
sword so much so that's that Joe yeah
man
watch Japanese spider-man hit us up on
Twitter
that's better Jay Gilbert had Joestar we
want to talk about what's your favorite
machine BEM who should Takuya have ended
up with Hitomi or one of the many boys
on it it's a it's a really insane
journey and we hope we could have opened
the door to this strange parallel
universe I wish
did this for every I wish they sold all
the Avengers to Japan hey your young
rider shares the same feelings alright
cue the sunset JT we're going home night
or good morning
[Music]
you